the whole reason we started the YouTube
was because we were on a skiing trip and
we were in a chalet and I have told the
story a few times but we're around a
table there was four youngsters and I
say youngsters 18 19 year olds maybe a
little bit older than that and for two
hours after dinner all they talked about
or asked questions about was business
and finance and I didn't know where the
time had gone I spoke to my son
afterwards he said look that's two hours
they were interested in what you had to
say I said what are they teaching this
and they went no so I think you get to a
certain stage in business where you
think this is all common sense common
knowledge everyone knows this but
actually it's the opposite they don't
and you know they're eager to listen and
to learn and to move forward